le penseur la méditation
le marcheur la porte de l'enfer
quelques-unes des plus grandes oeuvres
de rodin maintenant exposé au musée des
beaux-arts de montréal une première en
amérique du nord
c'est tout simplement une émotion forte
c'est ici on a des testostérones donc
plein les yeux c'est vraiment d'une
puissance d'expression inouïe donc on
reste rarement insensible à l'oeuvre de
rodin à travers plus de 300 oeuvres dont
170 sculpture pour la plupart prêtés par
le musée rodin de paris
on découvre le sculpteur sous tous ses
angles il a travaillé le marbre le
bronze
il a dessiné mais son matériau de
prédilection
c'était le plâtre c'est un matériau qui
lui permet sans arrêt de reprendre ses
oeuvres de pousser plus loin la
recherche
ces pièces sont un reflet du processus
de création qu'il a éventé de
l'expérimentation qui l'a fait avec les
formes avec rodin la sculpture existent
pour elle même donc elles s'offrent
comme elle est avec ses imperfections
avec ses coutures avec ses déchirures
avec ces fragments l'artiste français ne
travailler qu'à partir de modèles nus et
vivant un choix qui est prêt n'y sont
l'oeuvre d'une grande sensualité brodin
disait je n'ai pas de titre pour mes
oeuvres je suis connu pour faire des
hommes musclés et des femmes gracieuse
mais en même temps donc quelle puissance
rodin donc avait une fascination pour le
corps humain
donc il disait des femmes les femmes
marchent comme des chefs-d'oeuvre c'est
merveilleux non
l'exposition est présentée au musée des
beaux arts de montréal du 30 mai où 18
octobre
elle prendra ensuite la route vers les
états unis ici valérie michaela bayne
radio canada montréal